it's time for roses and rose a rose red
the color of blood we had a bloodbath
yes everyone it was a dark night on The
Bachelor and for that I have a dark rose
a very dark and a and a bad manicure
please ignore it I have to go to the
salon drink every time you cry or
someone cried on the bachelor don't
actually do that very dangerous on this
episode so it was a bloodbath and ended
in tears but we'll get to the tears
let's get right into the blood first
Taylor won how they act up we knew that
was gonna happen then an announcement
try to disappoint no cocktails already
that means some women aren't going home
we had to say goodbye to aspiring
dolphin trainer Alexis Alexis if you
don't go on bachelor in paradise I don't
know what I will do but one woman remain
women who win so excited
who are you nobody knows who Whitney was
that was the commentary that took over
Twitter don't worry you won't have to
worry about her too long whatever she's
Whitney then it goes on a one-on-one
with another brunette Christina and this
was the most successful date of the
night they really got emotional it was
very sweet
and Christina was very vulnerable more I
don't even know we're into it on okay
what's going to be Nick announced a trip
to st. Thomas
thank God drink for the fact that we're
finally going to get some Nick vile
shirtlessness drink to it what any
workout for if not for this chunk Oh
baby Giles heart so the ladies had to
st. Thomas where we briefly meet Lorna
and I've had to assist you all and
anything you need Lorna is a setup to
remind us that Corinne has a man the
women had out on a group date where they
are asked a lot of difficult question my
neck is for Holly yeah talk a little bit
off someone like specially now of course
on the show the women are competing for
Nick's affection but this group date got
very literal with competition they
played a volleyball game
oh and there was mutiny yes like I said
bloodbath left and right in this episode
these women did not want to play
volleyball I don't want to play and it
ended in tears noise drink every time
someone cries oh my god don't do it just
watch me I'll take the burden for
everyone and then there was fighting why
I'm having a little bit of anxiety right
now Rachel and Nick fought naked Jasmine
fought and Jasmine got a little weird
Oh shows you so bad Fatima success
yeah mixed reactions to Jasmine were
everything in this conversation like I
just want to like tore your heads down
and be like oh you know but I love what
nick is like really honest about how I
feel I know it's hard
sad but it's between the Chokey and he
was really honest with Jasmine it might
be time
he's not your land babe no pop her name
is Jazmin so and then throughout the
episode we keep getting sprinkled these
great little Corrine moments Corrine
just open her feet while everybody else
is stressing out their brain panic mode
to the two-on-one with Danielle and
[Music]
Whitney knows Palin so I'm actually a
Knick did a lot of leg rubbing to show
that he cares and we have a lot of
commentary about Whitney who newly cared
you know I don't know if you've noticed
but you're really beautiful
you have such a like it's really sweet
or about you but no no no Whitney was
sent home with nothing now here's where
things got crazy Nick then has a
one-on-one with Danielle who I again
thought was such a front-runner and Nick
again had a difficult question what is
kind of like one or two words that you
would go and way to describe a type of
relationship that you'd want it wasn't
actually that hard of a question but it
felt like a test didn't it watch next
base and listen to him during her
response
we're talking about here it feels like a
test
so I guess Nick didn't really want to
keep Danielle around because then he
sent her home
yes both women sent home it went from a
two-on-one to and none on one and no one
drink for Whitney and Danielle so the
Big Finish we've watched the women cry
all night and now must be mixed tears
but I just wanted to be honest I want to
be real with you guys
Nick went to see them and I I would say
as message was confusing um I don't
really know why he's upset he seemed
very in his head and I really wanted to
work out but I want to be you know but
basically Nick walked out on the ladies
and maybe the show I don't know Izzy
quitting The Bachelor obviously not but
it was pretty crazy so Nick cheers to
you for bringing the drama tonight I
felt like this episode really kick
things up a notch and I enjoyed it
what did you guys think so let me know
over on Twitter you should also
subscribe to EP on YouTube keeping keep
watching roses and Rose day and like us
on facebook where we do bachelor recaps
live every Tuesday not with wine now you
can only get the wine here
[Music]
I don't want to shed any tears over not
drinking this so here we go oh don't eat
or sleep just like Corinne